the president just capped off a very
busy day on the campaign trail
a huge massive rally and crowd in
winston-salem north carolina
look at this crowd look at winston-salem
tonight
take a long look ask yourself
um by the way that's not all the video i
wanted to show
how many p how many people feel this way
you can run the other video about the
weak and the frail
joe biden because earlier the president
also delivered a speech in jupiter
florida
where he was also met by massive crowds
meanwhile joe biden spent today in his
basement bunker doing nothing as per
usual we'll have that video in a minute
apparently he uh he needed the rest
after a very rough weekend
on the campaign trail more weird gas
more strange statements more constant
confusion
it looked like a mass deer in the
headlights
we're going to show you the very worst
moments from this weekend of joe biden
coming up plus we're going to bring you
a critical warning
that the rest of the media mob won't
tell you about and that is
mail-in voter fraud it is real this
coming from a democratic operative
who organized and coordinated mail-in
ballot voter fraud
in many previous elections and later we
have brand new disturbing video from
this weekend's far left riots
but first we start with a very important
observation
about the 2020 race 56 days from now
as we speak there is nothing that i can
otherwise describe as what is a
sickening sick ugly alignment
among so many of the powerful elitist
groups in this country
you got the democratic party there 99.9
you got weak republicans you know the
ones that always demanded
if you're a conservative you got to suck
it up and support their rhino candidates
the ones they preferred you have all the
deep state
bureaucrats that desperately want trump
out so
they can return to their nefarious deeds
and the 99.9 percent of the mob in the
media
99.9 percent at the new york times
washington
post all the print media for the most
part
nearly every single solitary so-called
cable news network they're all fake news
every broadcast channel abc nbc cbs
and you can add hollywood snobs and
elitist
then you can add now many pro athletes
they all speak in one voice
they're all working on one goal they all
want one outcome on november the 3rd
they want to beat donald trump now it's
time for a hannity history lesson
and what we call perspective because
remember
i know the four years have gone by fast
but the same exact thing was happening
four years ago
in 2016 same groups all aligned up
against donald trump
they laughed at donald trump's campaign
they mocked him from running
they all made the prediction ha ha he
can't win
almost all of them said no chance of
winning they orchestrated then
the biggest smear campaign in history
you might remember some of this
donald trump has been saying that he
will run for president as a republican
which is surprising since i just assumed
he was running as a joke
do it do it look at me
do it i will personally write you a
campaign check
now on behalf of this country which does
not want you to be president
but which badly wants you to run this
man has got some
momentum and we better be ready for the
fact that he might be leading the
republican ticket
i know you don't believe that but i want
to go on
sorry which republican candidate has the
best chance of winning the general
election
of the declared ones right now donald
trump
[Applause]
mr trump to answer your call for
political honesty i just want to say
you're not going to be president all
right
it's been fun president obama will go
down
as perhaps the worst president in the
history of the united states exclamation
point
at real donald trump
at real donald trump at least i will go
down
as a president donald trump is a here
today gone tomorrow
candidate for president of the united
states let me assure
every person here donald trump will not
become president of the united states
can you imagine donald trump standing up
one day
and delivering a state of the union
address well i can imagine it
in a saturday night skit donald trump we
project will win
in kentucky with its eight electoral
votes kansas
with its six electoral votes nebraska
with its five electoral votes
utah wisconsin arizona capping his
improbable
political journey with an astounding
upset victory
now as it turned out in 2016 we learned
their collective opinions predictions
were not only wrong but they were all
meaningless here is a
simple truth the washington swamp will
not decide this election
neither will those hollywood snobs the
truth is
none of these people matter their
opinions do not matter
fake news doesn't matter the power
rests with all of you look at north
carolina tonight that's not
the mob that's not the swamp that's not
hollywood elites
that's you we the people you will decide
you get to be the ultimate jury
in just 56 short days you the american
people
56 days will decide on the future of
this great country
the stakes they've never been higher by
the way
for informational purposes only on
hannity.com we have an interactive map
that shows you
everything you need to know about where
to vote in your district
when do you get to register when the is
the registration deadline
when does early voting stop start when
does it end and so much more
who's running for congress is there a
senate race in your state
make sure to check out hannity.com for
all the information and details that you
could ever want
this is the single most consequential
election of our lifetime
and the media the mob the democrats
hollywood elites
and all their allies they're not telling
you the truth they've lied to you for
four straight plus years in fact as we
speak
they're turning a blind eye to the
obvious and serious concerns about
let's be honest here the whole country's
talking about it they talk about it
behind closed doors they
democrats even tell me media mob people
even tell me
joe biden's strength his stamina his
alertness
and mental acuity yeah they're all
worried about it just like the riots
oh yeah it's a myth it's not happening
they're ignoring
a walking disaster in biden and they
know it
they're so desperate to beat donald
trump that they're
willing to put this country literally in
the position
of supporting somebody that would be
elected president
that is weak that is frail that is
obviously a candidate that is not up to
the job
the hardest job in the entire world
president of the united states leader of
the free world
for example during one virtual event on
monday biden struggled mightily to
answer
a question without a teleprompter well
actually with the teleprompter take a
look
i would like to know what will your
administration do to help them give them
that chance
thank you let's move it up here
you know there used to be a basic
bargain in this country
workers shared in the wealth their work
helped create
remember last week during a biden town
hall in kenosha wisconsin one person
actually had to complain that she was
being
forced forced to read off a written
script just think if this was donald
trump think for a minute take a look
i'm just going to be honest mr button i
was told to go off this paper but i
can't
you need the truth and the truth of the
matter is
we are heavily angry
not angry as to where people say oh
they're protesting they're
different if there's a difference
between a protester
and a writer a very big difference
the biden campaign they should be
ashamed if this was any republican the
media mob would have a field day instead
they just play along
they cover up the truth they act like
reality is not happening
they have zero moral compass
intellectual honesty or curiosity
it is such a disservice to you we the
american people it is a dereliction of
duty